here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show okay when you're on the
internet Richard Wolffe how do you see
the future of the American economy
wow that's pretty broad yeah yeah and in
30 seconds or 25 words or less yeah
perfect
forty characters or less yeah I think
what's happening is that we're coming to
a kind of crossroads and I think
Americans are more and more willing and
interested in looking at alternatives to
the way the economy has worked that's my
hope I think they're asking questions
about whether we might not have a
democratic way of organizing our
enterprises instead of having a tiny
group of people at the top making all
the decisions for everybody everybody
gets to D participate just say that no
that's part of the Tea Party right yes
the Tea Party I noticed almost always
has the same agenda as billionaires I
mean they're on the same page as the
Koch brothers it seems like a grassroots
organization like that would be at odds
with the agenda of the Steve Forbes and
the Koch brothers what would you say I'm
always amazed that people don't see
through this for the Koch brothers as
part of the top 1% if they were as
isolated politically as they are
economically being so the tip of the
iceberg and everybody else is in trouble
by comparison they'd be in deep
difficulty what they need is a mass base
they need some way to get large numbers
of people to allow them to continue to
be a rich minority and they don't
hesitate to fund and to find people and
to find some issue where they can bring
in some support so that they wouldn't be
as isolated as economically they want to
continue to be I think it's interesting
you use the term iceberg when you talk
about the Koch brothers because icebergs
relate to climate change and it's
exactly what they and others have been
setting up well people talk about think
tanks stink tanks to obscure the fact
that climate change is challenging the
fate of the planet I know this way but
icebergs only have like a full ten
percent of themselves out of the water
and the Koch brothers are way less than
that into the onedrive but I hate to be
right at the top molecule which is
probably to break it to you guys but
we're not actually funded by the Koch
brothers so that might spoil them there
I didn't say you were funded I
understand I understand but you know I
think that the real debate we're having
in this country is not about whether or
not we tolerate people that are rich but
whether or not we're still a country
where anybody can get rich and and when
I travel across the world
I noticed that our problem that people
can't get rich well it well don't we
don't we all agree that people should
have more opportunities and the lower
rungs of the economic ladder
I think most people are never going to
get rich I think what we need is
opportunities for people to get into the
middle class not not I mean I remember
Mitt Romney had a fundraiser I think it
was the Papa John guys house and he's a
rich guy he made money and the way most
Republicans make money pizza I don't
know why that is but the guy had a
private golf course in his own lake and
Mitt Romney said you know Democrats look
at this and say nobody should live like
this Republicans look at this and say
everybody should live like this it like
everybody can't look like this who's
gonna take care of the golf course in
the lake if everybody lived like this
but this is important if this goes back
to what you're talking about earlier a
wrong there robot is definitely a
definition of rich the definition of
wealthy the definition of what a good
life is has grown over time so that more
and more people live longer live better
lives have more opportunities and I
disagree with this idea that that people
are losing those opportunities because
it's all relative I do agree with you
that there's there's this problem with
crony capitalism and there is this
collusion between big businesses and and
big government and that keeps people
from getting in but what we go after
that collusion we don't go after the
enterprise system that creates the
opportunities and the disparity but look
the disparity between the haves and
have-nots has only grown under this
president it wasn't good under bush it's
not
it's like I'm sorry that's actually a
fact and the people who have even put
the present the people who actually put
the president over it is it is isn't it
is it had not the widening gap between
rich and poor is 35 years old in this
country's own into writing this book is
low and under this president much like
the same people who took this president
in office demographics like African
Americans what are you saying under Bush
as well I did it but then I did I say
honest that's the reality of that fact
that's all he's saying okay continues to
grow is my point
look that's no reason we get booked hell
I even said under I said it start under
Bush look I got no problem slapping
around Bush okay that's not the problem
here
what I have the problem with is that
what we're not when I when I can
absolutely say without a doubt I don't
either
we we as a party have a problem sure we
as a party have a problem or when I come
on these shows I try to explain people
we have a problem I have no I have no
issue with saying when we miss it
because we miss it in a lot of ways but
don't sit there on a high moral ground
and tell me that it doesn't get worse
under this guy it's been getting bad for
a long time so under Bush and now more
more so bombing the people that would
argue that he could not possibly be a
socialist so well if income inequality
is getting worse under Obama
could he possibly be the socialist that
they're always saying he is wouldn't
income equality social that's not
support I'd say many do I'm the rainy do
not know Europe I'm not saying he's a
socialist but but the people who put him
in office women african-americans
Hispanics their incomes have all gone
down they're jobless numbers have all
gone up really that's a fact I don't
know what to tell you but unemployment
is down to six point one percent when he
took office
sure okay okay okay I mean I mean I
think what's particularly sad in this
country is the continuum is the trend
whether it's the Democrat Clinton or the
Republican bush or whether it's a
Democrat Obama we are talking about this
continuum which is uninterrupted that
goes to the two-party system in this
country that really in the end doesn't
present a serious choice that would
challenge the income disparity in this
country right okay Neil deGrasse Tyson
what sort of event would it take to
energize American stem which is science
technology engineering math right those
are the degrees we call stem degrees
occasionally people put an A in there
for art and say steam just so you know
but tell my rise but that doesn't fit in
there that's fell steam yeah but that's
of course it fits to power it benefits
in the word it doesn't fit in the
concept well they try are these people
well that's stupid because they the
point of this is you just well you just
called him stupid no I didn't call him
stupid Ike I called gourmet ideas stupid
I'm caught putting it I don't think it's
your idea I said they did it but you
should it's which one doesn't fit
science technology engineering math
these are the things that kid is not
like
here you let me read yes
step we have no problem getting kids to
take art classes or drama class they
take twice as many graduate twice as
many people with drama degrees okay
that's not what we need we need science
technology engineering math it says how
do we energize American students take
these the way Sputnik did okay so a
couple of things the reason why people
want to put the a in there is they
recognize that art is a fundamental
expression of a human of human
creativity and and innovation in STEM
fields comes about when you're creative
that's the motivation for that but I
largely agree with you that is mission
doesn't really fit but it's it's a
little bit of mission Cleese dredd fine
so so I aren't smashed up I'm stealing
your caddy phrase so I worry that we
just have to keep sinking more deeply
until we all recognize that Republicans
Democrats and all other factions and
them in our nation have to align our
Pistons because we're all sinking on the
ship and we're all in the same shamp
right and but we've we've aligned our
Pistons before when Pearl Harbor was
attacked all the dissenting views at the
time came into straight alignment 9/11
9/11 we came into a line Sputnik we came
into alignment these are profound
moments threats that affect us it's like
the Conrad Leslie threat they appeared
to be threats we resort to our Basel
need to survive and then we agree with
one another with our paths and ideas at
the time I worry we have to say the rats
to future
all right that's right so uh it's not a
the best kind of answer of it right
should drive it but there there it is
there it is all right Thank You panel
thank you good man
ask bill and his guests your questions
right after the show at hbo.com or on
Twitter